[Music]
who watched Monday Night Football last
night
okay people just tuning in think you're
booing me that Conan is horrible
that was crazy did you watch this I did
see it yeah the fourth quarter yeah yeah
it was insane yeah Green Bay Packers
fans are furious after a controversial
call in last night's game Rob the
Packers of a victory yeah some are
calling it the worst call in the NFL
history since the black-eyed peas were
invited to play the Super Bowl I say not
that bad myself
I think that's here and this is their
know after last night's game it's clear
the replacement refs are a disaster yeah
right replacement refs that's not
working out well it just came out that
some of this is true some of the NFL
replacement refs used to work for the
lingerie football league they worked for
the lingerie football league yeah the
owners say they were forced to use them
because they couldn't afford the refs
from the Puppy Bowl Puppy Bowl
[Applause]
I can take that and edit it after the we
don't have money for that
okay our kind we also just don't care
yeah we don't care about I like an
awkward pause every now and then yeah
that's my new character
check this out gang in New York City
muggings for Apple products are up 40%
even worse if you have the new iPhone
people camp out overnight to mug you
[Applause]
[Music]
Lukie than that one McLean
this is a historic day for California
today Governor Jerry Brown signed a bill
allowing driverless cars in California
after hearing this amanda bynes said I
thought I had a driverless car folks a
new study shows that as a mother ages
she gets depressed if she doesn't
receive a phone call from her favorite
child
mm-hmm yeah I don't have a joke here I
just wanted to remind my brother Luke to
call mom in an attempt to bring back
more users myspace unveiled the redesign
for its website big redesign yeah but
it's gonna work cuz they've changed the
name from MySpace to free porn
[Applause]
that's my guy getting caught right
it actually works better this way at
home over the weekend in Georgia two
female police officers got into a brawl
in the parking lot of a Waffle House or
was that just a dream I had
[Music]
and then I gotta mention this a new
study just came out and you silly just
came out and suggests that if a man has
his testicles removed he lives longer
in other words married guys live longer
[Applause]
[Music]
I love you baby she's not watching as I
mentioned you're laughing really hard at
that and it's and it's just true